la plage s'invite à montigny le
bretonneux l'été en sable s'installe au
gymnase alain colas toboggan aquatique
structures gonflables au château de
sable petits et grands laisse exprimer
leur esprit créatif et voilà c'est de
s'amuser aujourd'hui dans le sable sur
les structures et toboggan d'en profiter
y fait beau donc on en profite à fond et
voilà c'est sympa à la basse et un
château fort là nous avons un tunnel
était presque fini et puis là nous avons
fait les douves et le château
et donc ça intéresse à votre enfant qui
sont venus nous aider ''je allison et où
bordeaux et après j'ai sauté après su
aller à dans une piscine carré avec
cette douzième édition l'été en sable
est désormais un rendez vous
incontournable à montigny le bretonneux
c'est pour permettre aussi à ceux qui ne
vont pas partir tout de suite de pouvoir
déjà se sentir en vacances
et puis il ya aussi des familles qui
pour des raisons diverses ne partent pas
forcément où voilà où nous ne partirons
pas peut-être du tout donc ça leur
permet voilà deux alors on n'a pas la
mère si on n'a pas réussi à l'emporter
encore m'écouter on ne désespère pas
près de 24 mille personnes sont
attendues durant l'été en sable une
animation prévue jusqu'au 18 août
[Musique]